字幕提供
大家好,我是全家小哥
剛剛今天來到了兆風政界的投資美感
台股近期來
由於大盤屢創新高
所以導致非常多人
就產生了FOMO的心態
就害怕自己手上沒有持股
然後股票一直漲
很多人衝進來
有的人做短線
有的人做波段
更多人是在做當充
這些當充的人也常常績效都不大好
今天會針對這個主題來做一下探討
因為當充你要耗掉非常多的成本
什麼叫成本呢
第一個你要手續費
第二個還有交易稅
當你來回反復充的過程中
其實你的成本是非常高的
那假設你當沖又沒有任何策略的話
那什麼叫策略呢?
就是你今天全部都憑感覺沖
這個當沖的這種狀況就會非常糟糕
就是會讓你常常小賺大賠
那這個又很多人對於小賺的過程中
他會時常害怕這個變成賠錢
所以常常在小賺的時候就先決定出場
錯失掉大賺的機會
那在小賠的時候他又想要拗回來
就往往變成大賠
所以這個投資人在賬面上的輸贏
會影響到他的心態
那這種心態就會讓他造成小賺大賠
第一個我覺得你假如害怕賠錢的人
你就不適合做當中
當你害怕賠錢
你的部位當然就很容易出現大賠
因為在你小賠的時候
你都不願意出場
在你小賺的時候
你都會拼命的想出場
所以第一個
當你很害怕賠錢
不適合做章衝
也就是說
當你手上沒什麼錢的人
完全全不能做章衝的
做章衝你的心理素質要好
心理素質要好
取決於在你的口袋要夠深
小賺的時候
你可能会想说你还要希望可以大赚
那因为你心理素质够强
你的口袋够深
所以呢你比较可以经过这种小赚小赔的震荡
那我们常常讲哦
这个做当冲会遇到四种状况
大赚大赔小赚小赔
你要先训练自己有机会遇到大赚
然后呢尽量避开大赚
很多人对当冲呢
基本上他都认为说就只有先买后卖
但是呢,我們經由量化交易的回撤之後發現
先買後賣的勝率是比較低的
其實比較適合的是做隔日重
就是說你先去買強制盧
那最好是它有鎖掌停
鎖掌停你隔天再賣掉
這樣子可以讓你增加你的貨益
那所以呢,通常先買後賣
假設你要做當中的話
你少了隔天跳空開高這一段
事實上你的貨益是比較不佳的
那最好的狀況呢
應該說這個在當沖裡面比較高的勝率
是在做先賣後買這一段
它又很吃這個盤中的經驗
還有很吃你對籌碼的研究
所以當你對籌碼有所研究之後
你的先賣後買的勝率會大幅的提高
那當沖本身也就是先賣後買的人
比較容易可以存活在這個當沖的市場上
但是先賣後買呢
它又存在一個陷阱
當你先賣的時候呢
你勢必得用龍券賣或是無券賣
可是無券賣呢
你會面對阻力強所漲停的這種陷阱
所以基本上呢
你做當中你要記得
你假如做先賣後買
最好是要避開當天盤面的強勢股
它可能是昨天盤面的強勢股
他可能今天还是强势股
那这种呢
这种强势股你要避开
你要做的是
昨天盘面的强势股
他有很多格冲
但今天呢
他明显变弱了
他整个族群都变弱了
在筹码上呢
他有很多值得卖的理由
这种的才比较适合做当中
这一定要关注这个筹码的结构
比较说
当你做先卖再买的股票
首先,这档股票一定要有格子冲
因为格子冲可以增加这档股票的卖压
第二,这档股票不能有波段的买盘
当波段买盘很大的时候
常常你会被波段买盘给嘎空
第三,最好要有波段的卖盘
因为波段的卖盘会跟你做同一线
所以整体来说,最好你空的股票是今天它有波段的卖压
第二有格式充的卖压
第三最好又有技术面的卖压
那这三个呢扯起来
你的当充的胜率呢
就可以大幅的提高
最多呢其实一个最重要的就是
均量比
什么叫均量比呢就是
当天的预估量除以20均量
那均量比最好是5倍以上
当它5倍以上之后呢
它很容易变成今天的
资金关注焦点
或者是呢
今天的周轉率跑到了前20名
然後前一天它是一個小紅小黑的狀況
不能是一個大長紅
前一天是個大長紅的話
你通常會引來一些隔鬆
所以大家今天開高爆量
其實有時候隔鬆是要出場
所以你做做的話
最好去找主要是小紅小黑
然後今天它的軍量又爆量
代表說怎麼樣
那成交預估量爆量
是軍量的5倍以上
今天有資金進來
最好同族群的股票裡面
它又有大漲的狀況
假如前一天是大紅棒的話
隔天追你的風險會比較大一點
因為大紅棒會有一些隔通在裡面
假如前一天是大黑棒
然後今天轉紅
這種也要小心
為什麼
因為大黑棒裡面代表說
有很多套牢的賣壓
所以當你今天進場,你又遇到昨天的大黑棒
因為昨天的大黑棒是一個新鮮的
那什麼叫新鮮的呢?因為它很近期
假如這個大黑棒是很久以前的
那很多這個套牢的人他可能已經出掉了假如是昨天的話,這個代表說很多人是剛套勞的剛套勞的遇到今天有解套的機會他可能會賣掉
所以大一棒也會有一些解套賣掉
所以我們比較喜歡的是
它的線型結構是比較多頭的
今天可能是小紅小黑
然後一根大長紅整個吃掉
前幾天這個小紅小黑的漲幅
也就是说一根大长虎呢
是创了近期的新高
它在面临功课重要关卡的时候
它会比较少解套的卖牙
那这种形态呢是我比较喜欢的
多方讯号我建议各位
一定要盘后研究筹码
就是说你今天想要做多这张股票
那当然想要做多这张股票
其实你前一天你不大能研究
因为你不晓得今天的这个主力呢
要去发动谁
你不曉得今天的議題是在哪一個主群上面
所以呢 多方發動之後 你要買之前
所以今天有訊號之後呢 你可以去看一下前一天籌碼
它是很多波段單 還是很多格子籌碼
那假如很多波段單 那今天就很適合做多
假如有很多格子籌碼呢 那今天就必開做多
所以做多方面是這樣的 就是
當你看到訊號出來了 你再去研究籌碼就可以了
放空的是你必須在前一天就要研究好籌碼
那通常你要放空的股票常常是前一天的強勢股
為什麼?因為強勢股比較多隔日充
前一天的強勢股裡面它必須要在今天又不夠強
假設昨天長紅拉漲停就今天開高8%那種也不適合空
因為開高8%很容易一下又漲停了
所以其實你要看的是
它前天漲停板
但是今天開盤是很弱勢的
然後它整個族群也都很弱
假設整個族群很弱呢
它一個人要再轉牆也變得比較困難
然後最好是它有隔日充
有波段賣單
有認購的賣單
那盤中最好會出現很多
這個創低的訊號
股賣的訊號
那這些都是屬於比較空方的訊號
當空方訊號越多
他就越適合做今天短线的先卖再买的
做空的一个机会
那这种做多的讯号里面
其实很多人做当中他都会看电视
看电视看头部老师讲什么
头部老师喊了就继续买
然后期待高档可以卖掉
那你在做这个行为之前
第一个你要先确认
你们家的电视讯号是够快的
因为有的人是看YouTube
他比这个有线电视
他在delay了大概半分钟到一分钟
所以实际上你看到的股票
在老师喊的时候
它已经先涨一段
所以当你看网路节目
你不适合做那种
看到这个头老师一喊
你就强劲去做短多的这种行为
这个比较不适合
那第二呢
由于这个有些老师喊呢
他喊的时候呢
他可能他的朋友们
或是这个知道是他要先喊的人
他会先预先先进去买
那等到买完了
老师喊完之后呢
它出現一個假突破的訊號
然後等到你看到這假突破訊號
你覺得整個線型都轉強了
整個技術指標都變得很好
你進去買
可是這時候你去買就很容易被出貨
所以我們說做多事實上有很多陷阱在裡面
就是當你盤中看到萬吉拉
很有可能是主力要讓你看的
要讓你討勞的
第一個是做多陷阱
第二個是做空陷阱
那做空陷阱是這樣子
它有時候呢 盤潛會先假摔
什麼叫假摔呢
就是盤潛呢
它會一開盤先往下殺
然後後面再擊打
那這個常見在
這個很多厲害的隔日沖的上面
就是它一開盤
它會先往下殺來右空
那這種股票呢
常出現在長期整理完
然後這個突破的第一根第二根
通常會出現這種主力右空的狀況
因為很多人看到格衝
可是他們有去看到這檔股票的型態
假設他是一個長期整理完剛發動的
這種千萬不能空
你要空的應該是高檔震盪
高檔震盪出貨的股票呢
他比較適合空
你不要去空那種整理完發動的
因為整理完發動的常常會有一個
空方的陷阱在裡面
那我们讲一下今天这个小哥做的股票
那今天呢我做的是记忆体的某一档股票
礼拜五的时候呢有些记忆体呢它是锁涨停
但是有些记忆体是杀尾盘
那这种锁涨停的股票
它的隔天的卖压会非常大
那这我们称为叫隔日补蝶股
那为什么叫隔日补蝶股呢
就是它的同族群股票呢
前一天在杀的时候
那由于这档股票
他被鎖掌平的牢牢地去鎖住他的筹码
不讓他殺
那這種不讓他殺的狀況下
會讓這檔股票少跌了一段
會在後面幾個交易日
有可能第一個交易日
有可能第二個交易日
他會開始呈現有補跌的狀況
那這種我們叫做隔日補跌股
所以各位呢
你要去研究好筹码
研究同類型股票的形態
盤中怎麼看筹码
最重要的是你要研究他自己的筹码
那格衝的行為是這樣子
格衝常常會買在漲停板
所以你可以這樣想
凡是買漲停板的,在九成都是格衝
所以這檔股票,假如某個分點
它1%、2%、3%、4%、5%都沒買
它就只買漲停
那大概率隔天它是想賣的
它不是真愛
那我們說什麼是真愛呢
就從0%一路買到漲停
這個每個價格都買到
這個才叫真愛
它在隔天叫不會賣
假如是只買漲停版的
那一定是渣男
那一定是會買的
我們來講一下關鍵分點
像前陣子有一檔股票在做廢棄物處理
看好坊間有一個新聞出來說
以後廢棄物處理只能找這家做
哇賽這檔股票連漲了好幾根
我們去發現
發現大家大漲漲停的時候
都有很多波段的籌碼下車
當遇到波段籌碼下車
然后呢买进的股票买进的分点是隔日充
这种股票呢它就很容易跌回原点
所以呢其实研究筹码非常非常重要
当你知道这个今天买的分点呢
它是波段的还是短线的
卖的分点是波段还是短线的
这种呢一定会影响到这张股票的后市
举例来说当买的分点是波段
卖的分点是短线
那这张股票呢就很容易继续往上走
那當買的分點是短線賣的分點是波段那這種股票呢就很容易大回收很多人都去看主動型ETF那我跟各位講你要看的是規模比較大的
當他在換股的時候
因為他是每天會調整
你就看他第一天大買
他就比較偏多
然後第一天大賣
就會比較偏空一點
現在主動型ETF是個險學
因為大家都在看主動型ETF
他今天在佈局什麼股票
但是他們佈局股票
有時候是一段時間的
他不會說一天打百萬
所以各位你要注意的是
第一天路完大買有可能會持續買
或者是他第一天開始調節的股票
假設第一天開始調節
他因為還沒調節完
這種股票就要避開
因為現在太多人在看了
當這個很多人在看的時候
他會形成一種共識
但是各位你要記得
你要去看那個規模比較大
規模比較小就不用看
地板跟天花板價
這檔股票的歷史數據的統計
舉例來說這檔股票到了天花板
95%機會會折回來
它的乖離率到了會回廊
到了地板
95%機會會回來會彈回來
那這個線呢
我們就要天花板線跟地板線
那通常股票到了地板線
我們會看它有沒有出量
假如沒有出量也不會去強反彈
那假如有出量的話
我們隔天開低、殺低、爆量
我才去搶反彈
那搶完反彈之後就要再等隔天
假設當天是有大反彈
那我們也可以做當中把它賣掉
假如當天沒有彈
我在隔天再觀察一次
在隔天假如又再殺低、爆大量
那這時候我會再搶第二次
那第一次搶的資金只有10%
第二次搶的資金
是我 但我所有想要搶反彈資金的也是只有20%而已
那我們整體這個搶反彈資金呢
只會搶我短線資金的30%
那這個是為了整體部位控管風險用的
通常呢 股票到了天花板的價位呢
我們是不會空的
因為呢 有時候到天花板呢
它只是一個波段漲勢的開始
那什麼樣的股票呢 比較喜歡做空
大部分就是這檔股票已經做完一個頭部的型態
各位你可以看一下
這檔股票創高之後回檔到月線
有沒有回檔兩次以上
假設回檔第一次又創高
那這一次就不算了
我們要看的是創高之後的回檔要兩次
那兩次之後呢
去看它月線有沒有走平
當月線一走平
然後呢
這一段過程中就很容易是一個出貨的過程
那我们叫做高档盘整出货
高档盘整出货
它会运用这种一天拉一天出
所以呢你会看到这档股票的K线呢
常常是一红一黑
那按照这节奏呢
去做短空的动作会比较安全一点
我们最喜欢的就是市场每天轮动
因为每天轮动代表说
它的资金呢大概只有一套
因为它今天买了就是要交割
就是得卖其他股票
那局来说像今天强记忆体
那可能PCB就不會太好
堅強PCB呢
太陽能又不會太好
堅強太陽能呢
記憶體又不會太好
堅強這個機器人呢
那個其他的租金又不好
所以呢
我們喜歡這種輪動格局的
你可以去找
因為這種輪動格局裡面
有些股票它一直在創新高
這種股票我們都不要去空它
我們要空的股票
一定要有一個做投形態出來
然後昨天長紅K一堆隔日沖
族群的很多類股的籌碼都是一買一賣
那這種一買一賣就是今天買明天就賣
那這種一買一賣的
你跟著它的節奏去做空
你的生率才能大部分提高
全證是這樣子
因為大部分的全證分點分成兩大類
第一大類是波段全證
第二大類是短線的隔日沖全證
各位你要先知道說這檔股票
今天大買的全證到底是波段還是隔日沖
那假如是隔日沖的話
那麼隔天它短線的賣壓就會比較大
那假如是波段全證
隔天就沒有短線的賣壓
所以跟各位講
你要研究全證來做當沖的話
最好是去找那種有隔日沖賣壓全證
就是它昨天大買
今天會大賣的股票來做
那這種比較適合做短扣
短扣呢你就要看
今天有沒有全身進場
你有全身進場的人
才適合做短扣
今天有買購的才適合做短扣
第一個你的部位不要下太大
因為當
部位一開始下太大
你整個人很緊張以外
第二個呢
你會非常害怕
非常害怕你從賺錢變賠錢
當你會害怕
當你會害怕從賺錢變賠錢的這一段
你就怎麼樣 你就不會大賺
你就不會大賺
因為你每次小賺你都想跑
即便你的勝率再高也沒用
為什麼 因為你的勝率高都是小賺
但是你賠的那一次呢 都賠很大
所以你整體你的期望值
你的風險報酬比是不漂亮的
所以呢 各位講 很簡單啦
這個你要做當初一下場
你就怎麼樣
你就設出價停損單
你的虧損已經固定了
你每天要賠的錢你都固定了
所以各位你要記得
你每天可以賠的錢要固定住
你可以控制好你的虧損
你不能控制好你要賺多少
但是至少你要控制好你要賠多少
所以控制賠這件事情是非常非常重要的
所以做當中你要控制好你的虧損
當你控造你的推損
讓你的獲利去奔跑
你才有機會大賺小賠
然後做當中呢
當你今天你做的狀況
不符合你的預期
你要想的是
你要趕緊的退場
不是要面對失敗
你是要重啟另外一個戰場
當你這樣想的時候呢
你就比較敢勇敢的退場
為什麼
因為你只不過把你的士兵呢
從這場戰役
去做別的戰役而已
那很多人不是喔
很多人呢
只要一虧損一賠錢
他就怎麼樣
他就跟這檔股票靠到底
就是一直套一直套
套了一直不賣
虧損一直變大
他對虧損呢
這個非常的怡然自得
為什麼
因為看到虧損他都不想賣
看到虧損抱得很安心看到賺錢呢抱得很擔心那這種行為呢只會讓他一直賠下去一直大賠小賺所以你要注意的是
當你面對虧損的時候
你要把它放大
什麼叫放大呢
哇塞這虧損
我賠一千塊
賠兩千了
看到這種虧損
你要趕緊的去處理它
那遇到獲利呢
可以抱久一點
不用那麼快處理
我們做當中呢
首先呢
你一定要給自己一個進場的理由
進場理由很重要
看你是要做短波還是做短空
要給自己找越多理由越好
據來說
短多的話呢
一定要同組選要夠強
然後第二個
今天呢
這個一定要出量
要出量代表有攻擊的
攻擊量出現
第三呢
它不能有隔日充足
它最好呢
有波段買進
所以第一個呢
你要去讓自己有這些進場的理由
越強越好
第二個你可以觀察指標
像我們的話我們會看連次量
什麼叫連次量
連次量是我用當中軟體
這個去把它
因為盤中我們是主比交易
主比交易實在太快了
所以我們會利用這個盤中當中軟體
這個去算它的連次量
那連次量怎麼算
就是我們會去算每5秒鐘
它的外盤成交量跟內盤成交量的比較
假設這五秒鐘外盤成交量比較多
那我們就會變成連次是一次
一次
然後外盤的它是紅色的
連量就會把這個外盤成交把它加起來
那當這個連次量
第一次的大量
它是一個攻擊的行為
那假設第十次第20次第30次
很多次的爆大量
再搭配吉拉
它就是很容易出現買盤的捷徑
那很多次都是內盤
連內次連內量它是綠色的
然後又搭配急煞
它很容易有一個賣盤的捷徑
所以你要觀察指標
它是第一次的供給大量
還是好幾次好幾十次的捷徑量
那這個會取決於買賣的行為
那第一次的供給大量當然是跟攤
那買盤捷徑呢
當然是你要跟著把它賣掉
所以第二個呢
我很重要的要觀察指標
第三
新材建設很重要
當你只做單檔股票
你會跟著這檔股票起起伏伏
那心裡呢可能就沒那麼健全
觀察兩三檔這樣做
那這樣做呢
你只要告訴自己
我今天
我求我自己的事
不要每檔都輸嘛
你至少可以大賺小賠
或者是有一檔賠了也沒關係
當你有這種心態
設好停損
你要追求的是
你最好是在每天總結的獲利
而不是每個單檔你都要賺錢
當你追求每天總結獲利
假設每天沒辦法獲利也沒關係
你追求的是每一週的至少要賺錢
假設這週也沒關係也沒關係
你至好這個月要賺錢吧
假如這個月呢你做起來
每個月做起來都有賺錢
那代表說你做的方法是正確的
那當你每個月都賠錢
你不要做了 去買iQ轉載
比較不會賠的
那當你每次做都賠錢
你要想想看
你自己一定是某個地方出了問題
那第四個呢退場計劃
是你在一進場你就要實行了
所以當你一進場
你就事好出价单
当你买进之后呢
你可以设2% 3% 4%
设停损
所以当股价到了你就停损
这就是你的退场计划
进场的时候你就执行了
当你有执行退场计划呢
你就比较不用去担心说
那我后面会怎么办
因为呢
你把每天的亏损都给控制住了
你才能去拥抱一个比较大的获利
对新手的建议
是第一个先求生存再求获利
你的方法一定要对
你的方法不对
很容易就阵亡了
所以要先求生存
你不用想说一次要赚很大
一开始慢慢做
部位放越小越好
当你累积比较多的实战经验
当你累积到比较多的获利
你才能慢慢的去放大你的部位
给老手建议
第一个戒除二喜
不要凹单
因為老手很多人會對自己充滿自信
充滿自信就很容易熬斷
就很容易從小賠變成大賠
第二不要急著賺了就跑
要養成自己最好有大賺的機會
第二個我們要建立新的機率
讓獲利奔跑
讓自己當作有機會可以賺到大賺
接下來你要有一個嚴格的盈虧比
那什麼叫盈虧比呢
就是你賺錢的獲利最好是放大一點
舉例來說你賺錢可能是5% 6% 7%
那你賠錢可能就只有2% 3%
當你的盈虧比漂亮
那你的這個勝率普通
會讓你整體會大賺
那你的盈虧比也可以醜一點
可是當你盈虧比醜一點
你的勝率就要很高
舉例來說
當你這個獲利每次抓2%
虧損抓3%
這也可以喔
但是你的勝率就要大幅提高了
所以當你的勝率跟你的盈虧比
兩者之間搭配起來
讓你的期望值是正的
你才能長期的留在這市場
這是給老所建議
這首先一定會看
這段期間
這個稻球漲跌多少
小納漲跌多少
這段期間呢
漲的股票呢
是這個國際股市裡面呢
漲的是哪類族群
這是最重要的
所以說這個一開盤
你可能可以去找那一種
這段期間漲比較多的來去做多
然後去賣那一種
這段期間跌很深的這種股票
要做一個條件
透過籌碼觀察還有短線的決策邏輯
可以讓你的當沖更有紀律
然後創造更高的勝率
好 謝謝各位看完今天的短線
當沖的獲利秘籍
喜歡這節目呢
歡迎幫我按讚訂閱開啟小鈴鐺
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜